attention nouvelle fraude en cours en
lien avec la coved 19
il s'agit d'une arnaque par hameçonnage
à propos de la pcu la prestation
canadienne d'urgence du gouvernement
fédéral
voici à quoi ça ressemble un texto qui
vous invite à cliquer sur un lien gbo
obtenir la prestation la même arnaque
existe aussi en anglais l'agencé de
revenu du canada dit et le répète elle
n'en voit jamais le message texte au
contribuable et n'utilise jamais de
messagerie instantanée comme messenger
ou axa alors si vous recevez quelque
chose du genre supprimer ça c'est une
arnaque
mais bonne nouvelle un nouveau service
de protection a été lancé la semaine
dernière
il porte bien son nom le bouclier
canadien c'est un système gratuit qui a
été développé par l'autorité canadienne
pour les enregistrements internet vous
pouvez installer ce système chez vous ou
sur votre appareil mobile et ils vous
donnent en protection semblable à celle
qu'on trouve dans les grandes
entreprises reconnaît les sites
malveillants et les blocs
évidemment comme tous les systèmes de
protection le bouclier n'est pas
infaillible ce qui veut dire que vous
devez rester prudent dans le doute
vérifiez auprès de l'organisme qui vous
offrent quelque chose si c'est vraiment
lui qui vous a écrit tous les détails
sur le site internet de la facture